Stop it.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
There's an narration
collected by
in his in his jam
and it's a statement of Abdullahb Mas
Abu Abdman,
one of the prophets.
Wasallam's most
closest
confidants, a scholar of the companions,
Abdullahbn Masoud, who is
one of the servants of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam as well.
Abdullahb Masoud
who is one of the first of the
companions to become Muslim in Mecca.
He says,
[Silence]
"Whoever wishes to see
the
a collection of verses. Now we know as
we've mentioned before
that the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam did not leave behind a wasa.
He did not write or leave behind a will
and testament that was written for him a
final will
when he passed away.
Yet Abdullahb tells us here had he
written one what would it have
contained?
Abdullahbn Mas tells us, "Had he written
one, it would have revolved around and
said essentially what these three verses
from surah al
say." And he mentions the verses from
surah al verse
153. Meaning that these
are
things that were revealed to the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
in the very beginning in Mecca
before all the other rulings and
legislations and laws of Islam were
revealed to him in Medina
sall.ai wasam. Yet these
commandments
they
were essential commandments that did not
change.
And these are not only essential
commandments that did not change for the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam but they
are essential commandments
that do not change for any prophet and
messenger.
All of the prophets and messengers
they come with a similar message in its
core. As we've heard before
that the prophet sallall.aii Wasallam
said,
he said, "We the prophets
are all
paternal brothers.
Our mothers vary yet our religion is
one.
Our religion is one. Our mothers vary.
Our mothers are different. Our mothers
here is a reference to their individual
specifics and intricacies of their
various laws that were given to them by
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
They have their each messenger has his
own book. Each messenger has perhaps
laws and details of those laws which are
specific and appropriate for his people,
for his time, for his place and that
take into consideration
the
continuous revelations of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala that will come after
him.
So all of the prophets and messengers
they have various mothers
they have different books and different
intricacies and details in those books.
However, their religion is one. The core
of their religion
is one.
There is a
center thrust. There is
there are fundamentals
that do not change
based on time and place. They do not
change based on who the message is
for. They are always the same no matter
who the message is geared towards.
And so of those things such as the five
pillars of Islam,
every prophet and messenger comes with
the five pillars of Islam.
Are they exactly implemented the same
way?
Meaning the establishment of prayer.
Is every nation commanded to make salah
the exact same way that we are? No.
There's differences. There's differences
in the way that the prayer is made.
There's differences in the times of the
prayer. There's differences in the
amount of prayer, etc. However, prayer
and its essential core essence, these
things do not change. Likewise, zak.
The wealthy amongst the community will
always
be required to take care of those who
are less fortunate.
Likewise, fasting, it has always been
commanded and written upon previous
nations. Thank you. It has always been
nations as Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
mentioned.
Likewise, pilgrimage,
there's always some kind of Hajj.
So, the intricacies may differ, but the
core
tenants remain the same. They do not
change.
And
for this reason,
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam.
The core tenants of Islam in Mecca did
not change throughout his time in
Medina. They remained the same. As a
matter of fact, the only thing that the
era of Medina,
the only effect that the era of Medina
had on those core tenants
was that they became more established,
more detailed, more fleshed out.
And so for this reason,
Abdullahb
tells us here in this narration
that whoever wishes to look at
a
a will and testament, a final will and
testament. Had the prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam left us with a
final will and testament, what would it
have said?
What would what would the was be? What
were the things that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam would have
desired to have left emphasized in our
minds and in our hearts? What are the
things that he would have most commanded
and left us with? They are the same
things that his message began with
saiam.
And those are summed up in these three
verses from surah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
he says subhanah speaking to his
messenger
[Arabic recitation]
say to them, "Come, rise up.
Let me
demonstrate,
let me tell you, inform you
of that which your Lord has prohibited
upon you all.
beginning with
the prohibition
and emphasizing that you all not
associate in your worship of Allah
anything
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
in your intention in your sincerity
that there
not that your sincerity not be shared
by Allah and another. It is only for
Allah alone without any partners.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala
that when you worship Allah, you worship
him alone without any partners
and that you direct none of this worship
to other than Allah. Oftent times we
have a kind of bird's eyee view or a
kind of macro
understanding of what a shik is.
Ashik is the opposite of
is the greatest act of worship. That's
what we were created for. And a shik is
the greatest sin. And it is the only sin
in all of the book of Allah that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
has made it upon himself that he would
not forgive. If a person dies having
insisted upon shik that this is not
this is not something that is open to
forgiveness.
Not because he cannot forgive it. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala may forgive whatever
he chooses for whomever he chooses.
However, it is because Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala has deemed that this sin not
be forgiven.
And so
often times when we imagine a shik, we
imagine it only in its most plain,
in its most blatant form. What is its
most plain or blatant form? Like
worshiping idols.
This is a type of shik, but this is not
the epitome of shik. Yes, this may be
the most blatant manifestation of a
shik, but a shik has many forms
and it
can infiltrate a person's worship of
Allah in many ways and it's something
that cannot be avoided by happen stance.
It is not something that can be avoided
by
the ignorant. It is something that has
to be learned in order to be avoided.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasallam
says in the narration of Abbas and Abu
Bakr,
he says,
he says Sai wasallam
in my
is more silent and discreet
than the footsteps
of a of an ant
on granite rock.
How silent and how unnoticed
are the footsteps of a of an ant
of an ant on granite rock.
This is how discreet and how silent shik
is
in the ummah of the prophet sallall.aii.
And so he warns us of this. This is
something that you have to go out of
your way. If you think about the
footsteps of an ant on granite, what
does that mean? Would a person notice
that?
No, a person would not notice it. It's
something that you have to look for in
order to identify. And for this reason,
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
has said
[Silence]
He taught Abu Bakr
the dua to make. And he said, "Say, oh
Allah, I seek refuge in you,
lest I associate
in my worship of you anyone else unto
you, and I seek forgiveness for that
which I do not know."
So this is something that a person has
to go out of his way to learn. It's not
something that you just know. It's
something that you have to go out of
your way to learn. What are examples of
that? There are many, many examples.
For instance,
astrology.
Astrology is a type of shik. The prophet
sallall.aii wasallam said
foram.
[Silence]
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam said,
"Whoever
learns
any aspect of astrology,
then this person has taken it upon
himself to learn an aspect of magic.
Magic is a general term used in the
Quran
to refer to more
and the more they learn of it the more
of a they are learning. He's making a
connection here between these two.
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam.
When we say astrology, what is
astrology? Look how common it is.
Astrology,
it is found in popular magazines.
It's found in newspapers
for decades, maybe even beyond that,
maybe even from the dawn of the printing
societies that
dist distribution to to the public
are the horoscopes. This is astrology
going to happen for you. If you're born
in this month, this is what's going to
happen for you. What type of person are
you? Are you an Aries? Are you a Cancer?
Or are you a a Pisces? And these types
of people cannot
get together. They make a bad couple.
And the best couples are this one and
this one. Right? This is astrology.
And the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said regarding astrologers
that whoever
asks an astrologologist and when we say
asks an astrologologist
doesn't just mean a person.
It also means that if a person were to
read the writings of an astrologologist
for the month or the year or what have
you.
Whoever asks
a kahim
about something
then this person's prayer will not be
accepted for 40 days by Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
Does it seem a minor detail?
It would mostly go unnoticed.
And a Muslim who engages in these types
of things and usually it is women are
more prone to these things than men are.
But it's shared between the genders.
And if you were to see a person who was
Muslim who engages in these things, say,
"Well, you know, we're just having fun.
It's just fun. We don't take it that
seriously."
The mere learning or looking into it or
asking will impede the acceptance of a
person's prayer for 40 days.
And the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
said, "And
[Silence]
This is one type.
Not mentioning other types of ship that
are pronounced or not so pronounced
especially in a society
made up of a majority of non-Muslims.
A society that you live in. We live in a
society as a minority amongst a majority
of non-Muslims.
And so we have to take extra care to
make sure that we learn these things and
these aspects of our religion so as not
to fall into these things unknowingly.
And not only that, but the bigger danger
than just merely falling into these
things is confusing these things as
being something that is part of our
religion.
And that is where the birth of
innovation comes from. And this is how
are introduced into Islam.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Allahbar. Allahbar.
Allahbill.
[Silence]
Ill.e.
A shadow
[Silence]
I shad.
Muhamad.
I was allah.
[Silence]
What the
battle? Oh,
[Silence]
no.
I'm more than
alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
Allah. for
you Muhammad. Wasam.
[Silence]
What? for
Allah Subhanahu Waaala
tells us in one of the final chapters of
the Quran
ever to be revealed to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam
in
the fifth chapter
of the book of Allah in the order that
it is as the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam left it.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us the story
of two brothers.
Two children and two brothers,
two children of Adam, brothers to one
another who had a disagreement.
And from this disagreement, the first
murder
in the history of humanity
was committed.
The first innocent blood
spilled on this earth
between two human beings.
Allah Subhanahu Waaala tells the prophet
sallall.aii
Wasam.
Now,
as we get into the story, it's important
for us to
keep in mind some context to this story.
Context with regards to when
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam was
reminded of this story and told.
This isn't one of the earlier chapters
revealed to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam.
This story was told to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam
in one of and some scholars say the last
chapter of the Quran to be revealed to
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. It was
revealed in Mecca.
It is the same chapter
in which Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says.
This verse
which the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
resided for the first time upon the
companions
on the mountain of
on the ninth day of
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
recited this verse upon the companions
in hisb
on the ninth day of
the year 9 after hijra
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
today I have completed for you all your
religion
and I have perfected upon you all my
grace peace
and I have chosen
and accept from you all Islam as your
religion.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam recited
this verse upon the companions on that
day
and he passed away 81 days after sui
wasallam.
This is the context in which this
chapter and this story was revealed to
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. What
do we understand from that? We
understand from this that yes now we
have the knowledge.
Now we have the knowledge of what is
expected from us. Now we have the
knowledge of how to obtain paradise.
How to worship Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and what are the things that will stand
in our way
after we have received this revelation
this book after we have understood what
the path is and how to tread on that
path.
What stops in our way and what will
hinder us? There are a number of things.
One of those things is we could hinder
each other.
That we are now brothers and sisters in
the religion of Allah for the sake of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Yet that brotherhood
is an incredible gift but it is precious
and has to be preserved and protected at
all costs.
For if it is not
then we could be our greatest enemies in
the path of Allah subhanahu wa tala.
As one of our scholars used to say that
this religion of Allah
and this dwa of Muhammad sallall.aii
wasallam is a miracle from Allah. It's a
miracle.
Why is it a miracle? With all that the
dunya has to offer, all of its promises,
all of its glitter and glam,
yet in spite of that seduction,
young men, young women,
people are turning away from the dunya
and believing in Allah in the last day.
and they are choosing to sacrifice
incredibly
in that path.
And the thing that we fear most
over our own dawa
is that we will be the ones to destroy
it with our own hands. Inadvertently,
mistakenly,
that we would take each other apart
because the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us he spoke to the
companions
that when Islam had been perfected
and when Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
to the companions
today I have perfected for you all and
completed for you your religion.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam
commented and said
He said
that a shan has fallen into hopelessness
after what he has seen from the
companions of him. and he has become
hopeless that he would ever be able to
swindle humanity into the worship of
idols again,
at least in the Arab Peninsula.
Meaning that when he saw the companions
and he saw how powerful the truth was
and how ubiquitous it became and how
bright
and sharp the light was and how rare and
runoff the darkness was as Shan became
hopeless that he could ever trick the
companions or the Muslim in the Arab
peninsula. to ever worship him again.
And so he resorted to
is starting
problems,
issues, bickering between the Muslim.
This is what he resorted to.
How was he going to
answer? And how was he going to try to
lead the Muslim off of the path of Allah
again after the prophet Muhammad Sam
he would use them against one another.
Here Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
of two brothers both of them are Muslim
they are the direct sons of Adamisam.
This is before any murder had ever
occurred. As a matter of fact, this
story takes place before any human being
had died.
Because as we will hear in the story,
after killing his brother in cold blood,
didn't even know what to do with the
body. It was new.
We know now that you can bury someone,
but this didn't occur to him at the time
because no one had ever died before.
This was the first human death and it
turned out to be a murder.
Allah Subhanahu Waaala tells the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam.
Tell them the story of the two sons of
Adam.
Each of them put forth an offering to
Allah.
One of them was accepted
and the other was rejected.
Now notice here, we don't want to get
bogged down with some of the details or
some of the things that are mentioned
in the Old Testament or in the previous
books from Beni is a people who ask too
many questions about unnecessary
details. Allah tells us what we need to
know about this story. What the offering
was is inconsequential.
What they were commanded to do or how
this offering was made is not important.
What is important and what Allah tells
us here is that two brothers, two
Muslims who are bound by blood and
religion and brotherhood
each attempted to worship Allah side by
side, but they had very different views
of what the worship of Allah looked
like.
And so one of them was accepted by Allah
and the other was rejected.
Now why was one accepted and one
rejected? Allah tells us in the Quran,
our prophet sallall.aii wasallam tells
us the reasons why Allah accepts and the
reasons why Allah rejects. It's not a
mystery.
In order for a person to worship Allah
and have their worship acceptable by
Allah, it has to meet two requirements.
Number one, it must be sincerely for
Allah alone without any partners. And
the driving force behind this worship
must be pure
desire for the pleasure of Allah and
obedience of Allah Almighty.
And the second condition that it be in
accordance with the commandments of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
It has to be done for Allah and it has
to be done as Allah has instructed.
If it is done for Allah and another or
if there are more than the reason of
Allah's pleasure behind it, then this is
what is referred to as a ship.
And if a person does it for the sake of
Allah, but in a way that is
innovative,
a way that is not in accordance with the
legacy of the prophets and messengers,
not in accordance with the commands of
Allah, this is what we refer to in Islam
as bidd innovation.
These are the two conditions for the
acceptance of any deed.
And so these two men are both Muslim.
They're both worshiping Allah.
Allah accepts from one and he rejects
from the other.
Some of the and the companions mentioned
that
and
were their names
and that Habil was a shepherd
and Kabil was a farmer.
And they both made an offering just like
we give zaka or make an offering every
year in Ala.
And so they were commanded to make an
offering to Allah from that which they
have. And so Habil chose the best of his
flock as a sacrifice for Allah.
And Abil chose the lowest
least
quality of his yield from his farm.
So we have two Muslims worshiping Allah
but two very different ideologies here.
Two very different ideas of the worship
of Allah. One sees the worship of Allah
as an opportunity
an opportunity to give the best
and to sacrifice the best of what he
has.
And the other sees it as a burden that
needs to just get rid of out of his
life. Just get it done, get it over
with. And he is of the med or of the
school of thought of
the least and the lowest expectation,
that's what I'll do. Whatever I have to
do.
So we have one who thrives in the
worship of Allah. We have another who is
burdened by it and sees it as an
impedimement, an impediment in his path
and in his business.
They make their offerings. One is
accepted, the other is rejected.
And so now we have
a classic case of
projection. What is referred to as
projection.
Meaning the one who didn't have his
sacrifice
accepted. He didn't say to himself,
you know, it wasn't accepted because of
me. I didn't do enough. I should become
better. That wasn't the attitude.
The attitude was, "You had yours
accepted. Mine wasn't.
I hate you. I want to kill you." He
said,
he said, "I
am thinking and contemplating about
killing you." His
response to his brother was, "Allah
accepts from the pious." Meaning only
piety in any act of worship will make it
acceptable to Allah.
Those conditions we mentioned, the
problem is not in his brother. the
problem is in himself.
But it's not easy to deal with something
that's in yourself.
That takes courage. That takes audacity.
That takes determination.
And most importantly, that takes
humility.
Most people can't muster that up.
It's easier to point the finger at your
brother. That's easier.
It's easier to say you're the reason
instead of looking into one's own self
and correcting himself.
And so when his offering wasn't
accepted, he didn't look into himself.
He looked at his brother and blamed him.
If you hadn't set the bar so high, maybe
Allah would have accepted from me.
You're the reason.
And so
he reminds him that the problem is in
yourself.
What does eventually do? Allah tells us
something very critical here. He said,
he says that his nephs, the whispers in
his in his chest, in his mind, his
nephs,
his self
started to rationalize for him the
murder of his brother. This is a
process. It didn't just happen
immediately. No, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala tells us
that the human being is most prolific in
argumentative in argumentation.
The human being is most argumentative.
The human being can rationalize any
atrocity given enough time.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us
but the human being in his heart of
hearts he knows what he's doing. He sees
himself even if he comes up with all
kinds of excuses and justifications.
Allah tells us about the hearts of men
and how we trick ourselves and how we
even lie to ourselves.
This man he agonized for days while his
nephs and a shan continued to whisper
and rationalize for him just how much
his brother deserved to die.
And so he killed him.
Why did he kill him? He killed him
because to him he represented something
about himself that he hated.
And it was his lack of conviction.
It was him falling short of what he
knows his potential is.
But he chose the easy way.
He chose to write off his brother,
to dismiss his brother in the most
heinous way. To dismiss his brother's
life, to erase him.
And notice in the next verse,
Allah tells us for this reason,
we have made it upon Ben
that whoever kills another
without right to do so, then it is as if
he has killed all of the people of the
earth.
And whoever gives life to another or
saves a life, it is as if he has saved
all of humanity. Why? What does that
mean? What that means is it's not a
personal issue. It had nothing to do
with his brother Habid. It had
everything to do with him trying to kill
something of his own self that he hated
and couldn't see.
and that this was one person who
represented that thing that he hated
about himself.
But if there were two, he would have
killed both of them or three or 10 or
all of humanity because the problem was
not in his brother. It was in his own
self. That's why he couldn't escape it.
And for this reason, my brothers and my
sisters, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
teaches us
that indeed the believers and only the
believers are truly brothers.
And in this struggle between the
excellent and the good enough crowd,
we are to either pull ourselves all the
way down or we are to pull our brothers
up. But our fates are interconnected. We
cannot escape each other.
The prophet sallall.aii
Wasam tells us that the excellent and
the good enough crowd, those who disobey
Allah and those who obey him, we're all
together, whether we it or not. And
whether we kill one another or whether
we find a way to get along with one
another, what my brother does affects
me. Even if I run to the ends of the
earth to get away,
it's as if we're all on one boat
together. We either all survive together
and because of each other, or we all
sink ourselves together and because of
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Stand shoulder tosh shoulder. Close all
of the gaps. Align your shoulders and
feet with the shoulders and feet of your
two neighbors on either side of you.
Straightening the row is part of the
perfection of salah.
Our reward will increase or decrease
based on how coherent our rows are.
Please double check your phones. Make
sure that they are silent. Do not join a
row ahead of you until Do not join a row
until you're sure that the row ahead of
you is completely filled.
Amen.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Amen.
for
[Silence]
Allah.
me.
I love my
Allah.
Allah
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
amen.
Amen.
[Silence]
Allah
Say Allah.
Allah.
Allahel.
[Silence]
Allah.
I'm in the cup. What you do?
My dear brothers and sisters, asalamu
alaykum.
Salamu allaykum.
I just wanted to give you a couple of
reminders inshallah and want to
request generous
donations at the end of the the the
prayer inshallah. first of all
there's going to be a zakat workshop by
Imam Ali inshallah on this Wednesday or
Saturday that's tomorrow. So tomorrow
after inshallah we'll be discussing the
zakat and how it applies and all the
rules inshallah. So it will be in depth
discussion. Please join and benefit from
that. There's a sister's halaka on
Saturday at 11 to 3. That's this coming
Saturday inshallah. That's a sisters
halaka. There are tjid classes and the
same time also 11 to 7:00 p.m. that's 11
to 1 inshallah on Saturday. on the
weekend program inshallah we'll have
that 10 to 2. That's on
the Saturday on on Sunday. I'm sorry.
This is a weekend program is on Sunday.
So I want to make sure we talked about
halatas and the zakat discussion on
Saturday. The weekend program is on
Sunday inshallah and that's from 11 to 2
or 10 to 2 inshallah. And the basketball
there are two programs that I think that
there's a lot of kids are excited and
they're participating in it. Please see
what we can do to benefit your kids from
this Portuguese programs. There are
basketball and the the soccer
programs and those are on Fridays from 4
to 6 for the basketball.
The soccer there are couple of groups
and there's the first one is from 7 to
7 to 9 year old kids. 7 to 9 year old
kids will be in group A and then group B
is from 10 to 12 years old and those are
on Saturday. So Saturday
and that's from u from 1:30 to 2:30
inshallah. So we have all these programs
they are tailored specifically for the
youth and please make sure your children
are able to benefit from it. If you have
any questions, please talk to brother
Jabber or brother Ali inshallah. So
brother or brother Hassan so we will be
able to figure out what your needs are
and how we can match them. Please donate
generously on the way out.